on peut dire quand même c'est vrai qu'à
partir du moment où il y a une loi gayso
contre l'antisémitisme mais surtout le
négationnisme qui a une loi Taubira sur
les Noirs pourquoi les les musulmans il
y aura pas une loi contre l'islamophobie
le bonsoir vous savez que Anne Dao
Traxel est la fille la troisième fille
de Jacques Chirac notre président de la
République voilà et Valérie daumin a
essayé de faire un livre au sujet de
Cécilia Sarkozy le livre
le livre qui ne devait pas paraître qui
qui c'est toujours un peu le même comme
un peu Palmer mais c'est le même sujet
si je comprends bien c'est le même sujet
voilà
il faut que je me mette au courant
tellement vous la dernière fois il y a
pas longtemps c'était pour Spartacus il
y a pas longtemps on se reproche Thierry
pas du tout au contraire moi je suis
ravi quand vous êtes là max vraiment je
vous le dire aussi ravi de vous avoir
alors cette fois c'est pour un livre qui
s'appelle fier d'être français chez
Fayard mais aussi pour un papier que
vous avez publié mercredi dernier dans
le Figaro et pour réagir sur cet article
j'appelle Jamel Boras
bonsoir
bonsoir Jamel
alors ce papier s'appelle Islam ne rien
abandonner à la politique de
l'apaisement alors vous utilisez ce mot
apaisement pendant tout l'article et
puis à la fin on apprend que ce mot
était employé au moment de la
capitulation de Munich par les
diplomates devant la menace de Hitler on
disait c'est pas possible on peut pas
aller à la guerre on va donc pratiquer
une politique d'apaisement et Munich a
été en septembre 1938 le grand moment où
on a abandonné d'ailleurs les Tchèques
les Tchèques on les a livrés d'une
certaine manière et on a dit on a réussi
la politique d'apaisement et Chamberlain
qui était l'anglais le grand ministre
des Affaires étrangères a dit c'est la
paix pour notre temps et
Churchill qui était dans l'opposition a
dit croit avoir la paix ils ont perdu
l'honneur ils auront le déshonneur et
ils auront la guerre donc même si la
situation n'est pas la même je sens et
c'est un peu pourquoi j'ai écrit ce
livre aussi fier d'être français je sens
chez nous en France à l'Europe
le refus de voir un certain nombre de
réalité et on entend parler d'ailleurs
le mot d'apaisement qui est un beau mot
le mot d'apaisement moi je suis tout à
fait un type apaisé et je suis pour la
paix mais le mot d'apaisement dans mon
esprit et dans l'histoire il veut dire
en fait capitulation il veut dire ça il
veut dire capitulation et je crois qu'il
ne faut jamais capituler
quand on est sûr de ces valeurs et ça
vaut pour tout le monde et je crois en
même temps qu'il ne faut pas voir ce
qu'on appelle la politique de l'autruche
c'est à dire se mettre la tête dans le
sable donc voilà le sens de le sens de
cet article mais
en même temps et je le dis à Jamel
Bouras en même temps je suis fier d'être
français parce qu'il est français et
qu'il a emporté sur les sur les tapis
certains nombre de médailles qui nous
ont qui nous ont tous fait plaisir
vous pensez quand même qu'aujourd'hui
face à l'islamisme voir à l'islam il y a
le même danger qui avait face à Hitler à
l'époque non il faut écouter si on parle
de Ben Laden des terroristes de Madrid
et de Londres de ceux qui égorgent des
gens de ceux qui essaient précisément de
choisir la violence et de et de tirer du
Coran et du Prophète la leçon de la
guerre et de la violence cela qui à mon
avis
sont une minorité si c'est ça oui c'est
aussi dangereux que le nazisme je ne
confonds évidemment pas
l'islam les musulmans avec ce que je
crois une minorité et c'est ça qui me
révolte si vous voulez parce que en
Europe où il y a une forte population
musulmane en France c'est la deuxième
religion il y a 5 millions de musulmans
dit-on puisqu'on a pas de statistiques
précises il y a la chance de voir naître
un espace un espace de paix dans lequel
nous pourrions nous rencontrer sur la
base de ce qui est la tradition
française qui est celle de la laïcité
même si elle a elle est imparfaite même
s'il y a de l'inégalité même s'il y a du
racisme en fait vous le savez et vous le
savez bien je l'ai déjà dit moi je suis
fils d'italien j'ai été porte-parole du
gouvernement alors que ma mère était
italienne et mon père était né en France
mais était fils italien en parler
l'italien chez moi donc moi je crois
beaucoup et je pense à vous madame je
trouve que et à Jamel Bouras je trouve
que une des caractéristiques de la
France fier d'être français c'est parce
que nous sommes depuis l'origine avant
même qu'il y ait une France parce que
nous sommes au bout de l'Europe les
peuples se croisent dans ce pays c'est
donc une terre où peut se jouer
actuellement dans les dans ce 21e siècle
ou peut se jouer vraiment une entente
mais il ne faut pas capituler devant les
gens qui nous manipulent et qui
manipulent tout le monde oui dans tous
les cas max
de caricature de Mahomet si notre
rapport au monde islamique qui est
soulevé et vous dit qu'il y a bien un
choc de civilisation oui je crois je
sais évidemment je ne suis pas partisan
d'un choc mais il faut c'est là où je
disais n'ayant pas la politique de
l'autruche écoutez j'ai regardé la
télévision
France 2 d'ailleurs où était interviewé
dans une mosquée de la région parisienne
un homme très émouvant je pense que
c'était un Sénégalais d'ailleurs et qui
disait avec beaucoup d'émotion être
sincérité il disait en se tape et il a
répété deux fois en se tapant le point
sur la poitrine moi je préfère voir
mourir mon père que de voir caricaturer
le Prophète alors moi je suis très ému
je suis croyant aussi je suis ému par ça
et en même temps je sais que nous avons
désormais nous un autre rapport au
sacrin nous avons notre rapport nous
avons vu par exemple sur une affiche de
films nous avons vu la croix ce film
s'appelait amen Costa-Gavras nous avons
vu la croix transformer en croix gammée
absolument ça voulait dire donc tous
ceux qui ont la croix pour emblème
aurait pu se sentir concerné en disant
on nous accuse de nazis au sujet de
l'attitude de pidouze pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale exactement si
vous voulez mais nous nous avons pris
l'habitude bonne ou mauvaise c'est un
autre débat mais nous avons pensé parce
que nous avons eu une histoire sanglante
nous avons eu des guerres de religion
nous avons coupé des têtes nous avons
massacré nous avons chassé les
protestants nous avons persécuté juif
nous avons livré à certains moments de
lait nous savons qu'il n'y a rien de
pire que l'intégrisme et qu'il n'a rien
de pire que les conflits de religion
donc nous avons construit ce que
j'appelle un espace laïque dans lequel
il peut y avoir Charlie Hebdo qui publie
des des caricatures mais en même temps
on n'est pas content on tourne la tête
je vois c'est affiche de Costa-Gavras
où je vois une femme à la place du
Christ je crois que c'était Nathalie
Reims dans une
scène il y a eu aussi le pape
si je suis très choqué qu'est-ce que je
fais je saisis les tribunaux je suis
habitué à considérer ma foi comme une
affaire privée d'une certaine manière
comme une affaire privée et là je dis
qu'il y a deux civilisations car dans
l'Islam pour l'instant c'est pas comme
ça oui c'est pas comme ça le sacré est
très lié au politique quotidienne en
grosses fumée
le Christ et ce sont excusés ils se sont
excusés et nous le problème c'est qu'on
ce qu'on ressent vraiment au fond de
nous-mêmes c'est le deux points de
mesure
nous il y a une espèce de deux poids et
de mesure qu'on trouve inacceptable en
tant que Français sur tous les domaines
il y a deux points de mesure et c'est ça
qu'on reproche mais je crois je vous
interrompre pour vous donner raison je
crois que ce sentiment de deux poids de
mesure je sais et je sais qu'il existe
que vous avez raison de avoir ce
sentiment parce qu'il est vrai qu'il y a
deux poids de mesure mais je pense que
c'est une je pense que là il faut que
nous y mettions chacun de notre chacun
de notre de notre bonne volonté je veux
dire par exemple quand je vois quand je
vois que Voltaire grand écrivain
français qui a dénoncé le christianisme
le catholicisme qui a été deux fois à la
Bastille
qui appelait d'ailleurs qui avait eu sa
formule il disait écrasons l'infâme
l'infâme c'était la religion catholique
il avait tellement peur d'être poursuivi
qui s'est installé à la frontière de la
Suisse et de la France Voltaire a écrit
une pièce en 1741 qui s'appelle le
fanatisme ou Mahomet le Prophète 1741 ça
fait partie des classiques quand je
j'apprends que dans tel village du Jura
en fait de l'Inde du Pays de Gex il y a
des associations musulmanes de français
je veux dire qui sont venus dire on veut
pas que cette représentation soit se
produise on veut pas parce que c'est une
on nous manque de respect mais peut-être
ressenti cela mais moi je ne veux pas
que ce qui a contribué à faire mon pays
le vôtre notre pays qui a lui donner cet
espace de de laïcité je ne veux pas
qu'on y renonce est-ce que vous voulez
dire en gros Max Gallo c'est que
finalement nous on a appris à faire la
part des choses entre ce qui était privé
et ce qui était public et finalement ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui c'est que les
musulmans seraient pas le faire c'est à
dire que au sacré n'est pas le même
voilà il n'est pas le même nous nous
sommes nous vivons dans un monde qu'on
peut critiquer qui est le monde de la
dérision vous le savez bien et on les
médias je dirais le monde de la dérision
se moque de tout se moque du pape
agonisant on dit que l'autre cette
panzerpo peut le nouveau Benoît XVI etc
on se moque on vit dans le monde de la
dérision et de la marchandise le sacré
il est expulsé une affaire privée on a
déjà fait une émission où tu me disais
que tu étais choqué quand ils avaient
insulté le pape oui mais je suis choqué
une ambassade tu commences ce que je
veux dire le pape j'ai trouvé scandaleux
que parce que Benoît XVI qui était en
effet il avait 14 ou 15 ans et il était
dans les jeunesses militarisées du
nazisme on a dit ce pape allemand on la
représenté comme un PAP nazi parce qu'il
était totalement vous êtes allé vous
êtes choqué mais vous laissez faire
je suis choqué et en même temps le fait
que ça se fasse me satisfait parce que
ça veut dire que nous avons quand les
peu à peu nous avons mis la religion
dans la sphère privée je vous pose une
question à quoi ça sert tout ça
la personne qui fait la caricature à
quoi ça sert dans quel objectif pourquoi
on fait ça moi c'est une question que je
pose pourquoi écouter moi qui sert à qui
sert le secret
nulles ce qui m'intéresse là dans
l'histoire des caricatures un journal
d'un noir à la fin septembre fait des
caricatures ça c'est la responsabilité
du journal danois pourquoi ont-ils fait
ça la politique du Danemark parce qu'il
y avait eu il y a eu il y a eu ce
cinéaste néerlandais qui s'appelle Théo
Van Gogh qui a fait un film et qui a été
égorgé par un Néerlandais
musulman et qu'il a égorgé et il y a eu
dans tous les pays scandinaves ça a eu
énormément de déco cette assassinat dans
les pays à partir et dans la zone des
pays scandinaves et en Hollande et
les Danois semble-t-il enfin ce qui
était à la tête de ce journal ont eu le
sentiment que la peur faisait naître une
autocensure que ça et profondément
choqué les musulmans danois je suis tout
à fait d'accord ce qui me choque c'est
que les imams danois de nationalité
danoise sont partis faire une tournée en
Égypte avec ses dessins et en ajoutant
et ça ça semble tout à fait prouvé en
ajoutant des dessins encore plus
ignominieux
que je n'ai même pas à décrire c'est
pourquoi je veux dire n'ont-ils pas
mener ce combat à l'intérieur de leur
pays le Danemark et pourquoi ont-ils été
embrassé
le Moyen-Orient qui a ses propres
problèmes
c'est la communauté musulmane je suis
d'accord mais je crois que quand on s'en
racine quand on est citoyen d'un pays on
règle les problèmes à l'intérieur de ce
pays en tenant compte des des valeurs du
système de ce pays et ça c'est ça qui me
c'est ça qui m'inquiète ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que les imams qui ont
pris ce risque je les accuse de d'avoir
un effet
provoqué aggraver cette incompréhension
entre les civilisations et et fait d'un
problème qui était réel en tout cas qui
devait être discuté fait d'un problème
réel un problème qui est devenu
international où vous avez des gens qui
sont morts vous avez des bâtiments qui
ont été brûlés ce qui n'est rien mais
des gens sont morts vous avez une
violence et une incompréhension qui est
encore plus forte et personne n'a gagné
sauf ceux et là je ça c'est mon idée
sauf ceux qui pensent
qu'il y a un danger pour l'intégrisme si
l'islam européen devient un islam qui
accepte et qui se trouve bien de vivre
dans un univers qui est tenu univers
laïque et il y a donc une tentative de
manipulation forte de ce point de vue là
c'est la provocation mais même après en
France il faut savoir que Charlie Hebdo
surtout François sont en déficit
François va bientôt fermer etc donc il
faut qu'il vende du papier et donc c'est
de la provocation et je crois qu'il faut
qu'on soit beaucoup plus sage que ça
qu'on rentre pas dans ses provocations
et c'est pour ça que c'est l'autocensure
ça devienne si on commence ce que je
veux dire si on commence à pas faire de
dessin pour pas choquer les musulmans
la liberté d'expression pour moi la
liberté d'expression et le respect font
partie son mari ensemble
tu peux moi je suis pour la liberté
d'expression mais si je vais blesser une
personne pourquoi le blesser la personne
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le mot respect
car je l'ai j'ai beaucoup lu ces
temps-ci des cris notamment de Tariq
Ramadan par exemple et il dit il faut
que les musulmans ne réclament pas plus
de censure mais il réclame davantage de
respect le seul problème c'est que si le
respect c'est ça aboutit en fait à une
censure par exemple le porte-parole de
la mosquée de Genève et je cite enfin
vous pouvez vérifier mes sources quand
on voulait faire la lecture à Genève
récemment un mois de cette pièce de
Voltaire
de Voltaire qui s'appelle le fanatique
ou Mahomet le Prophète il a dit nous
sommes pour la liberté d'expression mais
nous voulons le respect mais si le
respect aboutit à la censure alors à ce
moment-là soyons clairs disons disons
nous nous considérons que tout ce qui
est attentatoire et blasphématoire pour
nous ne doit pas avoir droit de cité au
moins c'est clair de la France il est
c'est un melty potes enfin très mélangé
avec pour moi c'est très riche il faut
que il faut que plutôt rassembler les
idées qui nous unissent tout le monde
est d'accord avec toi la France est
d'accord mais si moi j'ai envie de faire
une caricature sur Mahomet ou sur un
rabbin ou sur Jésus-Christ il faut que
j'ai le droit de le faire tu comprends
la France Thierry
à mon avis comme tout à l'heure on
parlait il faut que tu sois dans
l'empathie quand tu sais que tu vas
blesser 10 millions de personnes
pourquoi tu vas les blesser pourquoi
c'est la liberté c'est ça c'est la
liberté alors pas de poids de mesure la
liberté pour tout le monde
c'est à dire la liberté pour tout le
monde il y a des personnes qui ont été
refusées de télévision tu as des
personnes qui
une personne comme Dieudonné qui a fait
un rabbin enfin qui a fait un colon juif
etc tous ces DVD ne sont plus dans les
packs on l'empêche de venir on l'empêche
médiatiquement on le voit plus alors que
lui c'est un comique et qu'il a il est
où c'est vrai qu'il a pas été condamné
qu'on fasse confiance à la loi
à la République
est intéressant en l'occurrence c'est
vrai ce qui est justement ce qui me gêne
dans la censure c'est qu'elle est
souvent exercée par un une poignée de
personnes par en tout cas sans aucun
respect pour ceux qui sont en face c'est
à dire que on ne laisse pas le choix
aux gens qui qui sont en face de juger
par eux-mêmes ces dessins ils ont ils
existent j'ai le droit moi de dire ça me
choque où j'ai le droit de moi de dire
je les trouve bien et puis je veux qu'il
y en ait d'autres ou alors il faut pas
faire ça mais je veux dire chacun est
responsable de de de ses pensées de et
donc je pense que la censure elle n'est
pas acceptable parce qu'on est chacun on
faut il faut le respect de chacun on est
chacun digne d'un avis et je trouve ça
choquant de dire toi tu ne verras pas
ses dessins parce que c'est des seins
sont choquants et vont provoquer des
violences en quoi
c'est acceptable moi je trouve que on
est tous on doit être tous responsable
et que si ce n'est pas le cas c'est ça
qu'il faut régler le problème c'est de
savoir pourquoi et des manifestations
violentes le problème de savoir pourquoi
quand on n'est pas d'accord on ne
manifeste pas dans l'apaisement c'est à
dire sereinement on n'est pas d'accord
mais on le disant et non pas en faisant
des actes violents mais mon avis c'est
ça qu'il faut régler et non pas dire il
ne faut pas qui est telle chose il faut
pas qu'on écrive telle chose il faut pas
qu'on dessine telle chose parce que vous
comprenez messieurs dames tout ça va
provoquer des violences non moi j'ai pas
dit ça
alors moi j'ai pas dit ça elle a dit
quelque chose d'important c'est clair
quand elle parle de liberté d'expression
elle a dit un mot important à
responsabilité c'est qu'un journaliste
il doit avoir une responsabilité un
politique doit avoir une responsabilité
un philosophe doit avoir une
responsabilité aussi tout à fait ça
c'est très important le mot qu'elle a
dit moi j'ai jamais dit que j'étais pour
la violence loin de là il y a juste un
truc important j'aimerais dire il y a eu
la loi tauberra d'accord il y a eu
plusieurs lois qui ont été faites contre
l'antisémitisme que je trouve
extraordinaire je trouve et moi je fais
un appel aujourd'hui
au ministre tout à Taza qui est là
où de Villepin de faire une loi contre
l'islamophobie
tout simplement
tous ces problèmes
des des historiens et d'autres et
d'autres d'autres
intellectuels emploie Urmo je suis pas
pour que des je pense qu'il y a des lois
en France qui sont contre le racisme
contre l'antisémitisme il y a des lois
sur la presse contre la diffamation on
peut poursuivre on peut demander la
saisie d'un journal en référé on a
d'ailleurs demandé la saisie de Charlie
Hebdo mais il y avait un vice de
procédure l'avocat la reconnu il s'est
pris tard etc il y a donc un ensemble de
lois nous n'avons pas à fixer par la loi
un certain nombre de règles parce qu'on
peut dire quand même c'est vrai qu'à
partir du moment où il y a une loi gayso
contre l'antisémitisme et surtout le
négationnisme qui a une autobi rare sur
les Noirs pourquoi les les musulmans il
y aura pas une loi contre l'islamophobie
je dis pas que si je dis Ben Laden est
un criminel
se réclame du Prophète ça c'est pas
nécessaire il serait quand même du
Prophète
chaque instant ce qui égorge les gens
disent nous nous agissons au nom du
Prophète personne égorge j'ai rien du
tout on parle de problème arrêter de
nous chercher toujours les problèmes on
n'a rien en France il y a pas de
banglades il y a pas de souci est une
notion qui est extrêmement vague je veux
dire si je me mets à critiquer d'un
point de vue athée si je me mets à
critiquer l'islam et si je fais la
lecture du Coran je fais une lecture qui
est considéré comme je prends sa Salman
Rushdie qui est considéré comme
satanique alors je suis victime de la
loi de l'islamophobie ça veut dire que
ça m'interdit d'analyser telle et tel
texte considérer sacré par un effet
musulman qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
c'est une personne qui prie sur Dieu et
sur son prophète tous les jours
qui pour lui dans ses convictions le
prophète est au-dessus de ses parents
ça correspond bien à ce que disait une
personne mais une bombe sur la tête du
Prophète ça veut dire que quoi 1
milliard 500 millions de musulmans sont
des terroristes et sont des mecs qui
vont poser des bombes n'oublie pas parce
que vous nous parlez d'histoire en tant
qu'historien très souvent mais personne
nous rappelle l'histoire de l'Andalousie
ou quand les musulmans étaient au
pouvoir ils défendaient les juifs et les
chrétiens on peut tout à fait de l'image
ou dans le monde entier où les trois
religions vivaient à merveille personne
nous la rappelle à l'époque d'Avicenne
ou à l'époque de d'avéro S ou à l'époque
de personne ou la rappelle c'est
l'histoire et tout à fait aujourd'hui il
y a un an de ça j'ai fait un appel il y
a un film qui est merveilleux qui est
tourné par Anthony Quinn et Irène papas
qui est le messager qui explique
l'histoire de la religion
comment elle est arrivée etc etc un film
magnifique il est passé en 78 79 dans
les Dossiers de l'écran d'art mangé un
mot comment ça se fait qu'il repasse pas
la télévision depuis 26 ans je ne suis
pas je peux pas vous répondre je suis
vraiment moi c'est toutes des questions
que je pose à chaque fois justement on
va continuer dans les questions parce
qu'on va sortir un peu des caricatures
de Mahomet la séparation des hommes et
des femmes dans les piscines par exemple
ou le fait que certaines patientes
musulmanes refusent de se faire soigner
par des médecins hommes est-ce que ça te
choque en tant que musulman les deux
points de mesure c'est aujourd'hui les
chrétiens
dans toutes les grandes villes sont en
place ils ont leur ils ont leur ils ont
leurs écoles etc etc il y a la
communauté juive qui a réussi à
créer ces écoles etc nous le problème
c'est que les musulmans ne sont pas
organisés ils ont pas mis leurs écoles
si parce que si tu es pas d'accord avec
l'école publique tu as qu'à faire ton
école
tu as qu'à faire ton école comme ça tu
as ta piscine tu attends tu as tes
séparation etc etc c'est à eux de
s'organiser et de faire leurs écoles
c'est la fin de l'universalisme
républicain
on le laisse faire à d'autres et pas du
mal je veux dire à un moment moi c'est
ça moi je veux une loi pour tout le
monde et c'est la même pour tout le
monde c'était ça c'est ça qui me
principe c'est le principe même de la
République je ne dis pas que ça existe
dans les faits mais notre projet le
projet français c'est celui-là
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que le lien
entre la nation française et celui qui
fait partie de cette collectivité est un
lien personnel un lien personnel de
citoyen d'individus si nous ne
préservons pas cette singularité
française
imparfaite aujourd'hui je suis d'accord
imparfaite mais si nous ne la préservons
pas et bien nous serons une nous serons
une série de communautés éclates vous
pensez max que c'est une capitulation
c'est d'accepter que les piscines soient
une capitulation on rampante
capitulation rampante qui n'a pas besoin
de de d'expression violente mais qui
fait qui est il existe des groupes de
pression des gens viennent et par
précisément parce qu'on ne croit plus à
notre système de valeurs à ce que nous
avons bâti difficilement à ce qui n'est
pas parfait à ce moment-là on accepte et
on crée on crée des piscines pour les
femmes on crée bref on va accepter que
la pièce de Voltaire ne soit pas
représentée on va accepter que tel
journal ne puisse pas reproduire si ça
lui chante et même si je pense que c'est
tout à fait stupide qu'il pro qu'il
passait ou tel caricature et puis
surtout je crois je veux répondre à
Jamel sur ce point qui a dit les
catholiques sont installés les Juifs
sont installés avec leurs écoles etc
tout à fait la vérité mais il faut
admettre Jamel c'est comme ça et je le
dis avec beaucoup de calme et sans
supériorité que le socle de cette France
et de cette Europe est un socle
judéo-chrétien pourtant mon grand-père
quand il a fait la guerre pour la France
qu'on lui amené et qu'on lui amené à
manger et quand c'est ma grand-mère elle
avait le foulard personne ne l'a dit que
tu étais musulman et que tu as été
différent des autres si comme je l'ai
entendu comme je me le suis entendu dire
à savoir la phrase suivante dans un
débat télévisé il y a 4 ou 5 ans
quelqu'un qui m'a dit vous avez des
églises partout dans tous les villages
nous nous n'avons pas de mosquée moi je
suis pour qu'on construise des mosquées
je suis pour que vous ne priez pas dans
les dans les dans les sur les trottoirs
parce que moi il y a des églises qui ne
servent à rien on prend même les églises
on a le droit à ne pas
prier dans des églises mais ne pas
admettre la réalité historique de ce
pays je veux dire qui ce pays a un je
regrette à un socle judéo-chrétien c'est
comme ça comme l'Europe on peut on peut
le regretter on peut dire ça va changer
dans 100 ans ce sera différent peut-être
mais n'empêche que c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui et c'est que tu es encore
que c'est pour ça que nous la jeunesse
on est là pour essayer de changer les
choses pour faire
encore je veux dire la jeunesse soyons
soyons clairs
le problème de la France le problème de
la France
et de faire vivre ensemble toutes les
jeunesses toutes les jeunes sur toute la
jeunesse toutes les jeunesses pas
seulement vous ne ce n'est pas vous qui
êtes seulement la jeunesse il y a toutes
les jeunesses de ce samedi que j'étais
la jeunesse
transition transition on arrive
maintenant plus précisément au livre
donc il s'appelle fier d'être français
et vous dites c'est la première phrase
du livre il faut bien que quelqu'un
monte sur le ring et disent je suis fier
d'être français donc c'est vous qui vous
y êtes collé max bah écoutez oui je me
suis collé ça je suis peut-être pas le
mieux placé puisque je le répète on
parlait italien chez moi il y a 50 ans
ou 60 ans donc mais il n'empêche que je
suis français et je reconnais que je
suis très attaché à ce pays qui est mon
pays je participais à sa vie et il m'a
donné en même temps le moyen par l'école
de la République moi fils d'un milieu
prolétariat d'immigrés il m'a donné le
moyen de faire un parcours soit bon ou
mauvaise de notre débat mais j'ai fait
un parcours je n'ai pas rencontré de
racisme même si chez moi on en a
souffert moi personnellement je n'en ai
pas rencontré et je ne pense pas que la
France soit un pays raciste et même s'il
y a des racistes en France même si
d'accord avec vous même s'il y a des
racistes la France mais nous sommes
comme partout
nous ne sommes pas un pays raciste les
Français ne sont pas du tout
islamophobes absolument ça c'est parce
que mais il y a des certains
intellectuels c'est tout quelques
politiques mais c'est vrai non ce que
vous dites vous on a eu ici pas mal de
déclinologues là depuis quelques temps
vous en prenez au déclinologue et je
m'en prends je vais vous dire je m'en
prends à ce que j'appelle les élites je
vous dis simplement les élites j'en fais
apparemment peut-être partie mais par
mon mode de vie je me sens pas moi
membre du délire mais j'en prends aux
élites qui qui ont pensé à un moment
donné que les nations c'était fini la
France c'était fini et quand vous
entendez cette France est déjà Albert
Camus l'écrivait il y a longtemps cette
France comme si elle était la seule
coupable parmi des nations qui seraient
Saintes et purée ben non nous sommes pas
meilleurs que les autres mais nous
sommes pas pire et même à certains
moments je trouve que nous avons dans
l'histoire des hommes nous avons joué un
rôle positif par exemple quand nous
avons créé cet espace de vie en commun
imparfait je le répète mais qui a été
créé quand même donc vous êtes contre la
repentance généralisée la France qui
s'accuse de tous les crimes et qui a
honte de ce qu'elle a été vous utilisez
tant de redresser la tête et d'en finir
avec la repentance quoi bien sûr parce
que vous ne pouvez pas vous ne pouvez
pas regarder c'est comme et là je pense
que Jamel sera d'accord avec moi on ne
peut pas regarder
son passé le sien propre en tant que
personne
comme un univers négatif noir et avancé
il faut avoir de l'estime de soi il faut
avoir de l'estime de soi il faut être
fier de ses origines il faut mais les
regarder lucidement par en faire un
palais mais les regarder avec leurs
ombres et leurs lumières comme on dit et
c'est comme ça qu'on avance il faut
aussi avoir l'humilité et de dire on
s'est trompé absolument tout à fait de
demander des excuses à des peuples qu'on
a qu'on a dessiné ou qu'on a qu'on a
massacré oui bien sûr pourquoi pas ça
c'est le code moral
d'accord prenons les choses tout à fait
frontalement jugeons de la colonisation
française par exemple la colonisation
française moi j'ai toujours dit écrit
dans tous les débats j'ai beaucoup
participé la colonisation a un péché
originel la colonisation c'est une
conquête militaire par des gens plus
forts qui oppriment des gens plus
faibles donc quoi que vous construisiez
des des pores des immeubles 1000 des
institutions par les indigènes tu vois
que quoi que nous laissions de positif
ce sera toujours affecté d'un signe
négatif parce que la blessure et c'est
normal mais si on veut juger ça il faut
comparer par rapport à quoi par rapport
à la colonisation anglaise par rapport à
la colonisation allemande par rapport à
ce qui se faisait à l'époque là nous
sommes dans la réalité et à ce moment-là
nous voyons que nous sommes pas du tout
les pires ah non au contraire nous
sommes pas du tout
si vous dites si vous accusez si vous
regardez seulement la France en disant
criminel colonisation etc faites non non
il faut condamner toutes les
colonisations non qu'elles soient
anglaises qu'elles soient pour comparer
pour juger il faut comparer les choses
faut comparer les choses alors ce qui
veut dire c'est qu'en France il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui trouvaient que la
colonisation a coûté trop cher parce que
ça coûtait de l'argent tout ça et qu'il
y a le fameux Raymond quartier qui
disait la Corrèze plutôt que le zambès
et puis nous sommes un contradictoires
il y a toujours eu en France des
opposants à la colonisation non pas non
pas simplement pour des raisons
économiques qui disent ça coûte plus
cher ça coûte trop cher on ferait mieux
d'investir dans les routes en Corrèze ou
ailleurs par exemple mais il y a des
gens qui étaient opposés à la
colonisation pour des raisons tout à
fait morales Clémenceau disait à Jules
Ferry vous nous parlez de race
supérieure mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire moi je suis pour je suis pas du
tout à dans cette optique là ces gens-là
étaient étaient du côté des colonisés et
ils étaient français donc ne confondons
pas une sorte de culpabilité collective
qui écrase le pays c'est pas possible
très bien alors vous dites max galop
pour vous le vainqueur en 2007 sera
celui qui sera capable de restituer aux
Français cette capacité d'être fier
d'être français mais oui je crois que
l'élection ne se jouera pas sur des
questions de pas seulement en tout cas
et pas d'abord sur des questions de
savoir contrat premier embauche je crois
que c'est je crois que nous bon à un
moment où on a besoin de de savoir dans
quel pays on vit et ce qu'on veut faire
de ce pays et c'est ça qui sera la
question
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu